Here we will use the Short Match functionality in
the UCSC Genome Browser to find a short sequence
motif within our contig. Before we get started, go
to the Genome Browser Gateway page and select the
D. melanogaster genome and the August 2014 BDGP
Release 6 + ISO1 MT/dm6 assembly. Enter
chr2r:18,867,350 -18,867,430 into
the search term field and click submit.
This region contains the transcription start site
of the Drosophila melanogaster DptB gene. Short
match can be used to search for short sequences
between 2 and 30 bases long. For this example, we
will use short match to search for the initiator
motif or Inr. The Inr is a motif that is associated
with the RNA polymerase II core promoter and
previous studies suggest that transcription factor
IID or TFIID binds specifically to this motif. The
Inr motif when found typically begins two bases
upstream of the transcription start site though
the location of the motif can vary by a few bases.
The consensus sequence for the Inr motif in
Drosophila is six bases long running in the
same orientation as the gene. To use Short
Match, locate the Mapping and Sequencing
Tracks section within the Genome Browser
and click on the Short Match link. Change
the Display mode field to "pack" and type TCAKTY
into the Short 2-30 base sequence field.
Note that TCAKTY is the consensus
sequence for the Inr in Drosophila.
K represents keto, either guanine or thymine, and Y
represents pyrimidine, either cytosine or thymine.
After changing the display mode and typing
in the consensus sequence, click submit. You
will see Perfect Matches to the Short Sequence
that you typed appear as black bars within the
browser window. The label next to the black
bar describes the orientation and the start
position of the motif match. In this case, the Inr
motif is located three nucleotides downstream
of the annotated transcription start site of
DptB at 18,867,394 in the positive orientation.